hi everyone my name is Danny Goldstein
I'm a grad student here at Berkeley
Peter Nugent who spoke in the last
session is my advisor and today I want
to tell you about how we actually find
the changes in the night sky that Peter
talked about what are the algorithms
that we actually use to detect sources
that are moving changing in brightness
or actually just appearing where there
wasn't any source of light before and
just as an example of this you know here
here are some before after and different
photos of supernovae just one very small
region of sky over a couple years and so
what I'd like to do is convince you that
now this has become a real-time decision
making problem I want to give you a
sense of some of the strategies and
techniques we've developed to deal with
it and then just end with a little bit
of a picture of the science outlook now
that we've been able to to kind of get
this under control but before I jump
into supernova detection as a real-time
decision making problem I want to talk a
little bit about went supernova
detection and finding new objects on the
sky was not a real-time decision making
problem so so this is actually an
instrument from the 1930s that's called
a blink comparator and this is how this
is how this problem was solved for the
vast majority of the 20th century
basically you'd go out one night with
your telescope and you'd point it at
some region of the sky and put a
photographic plate at the focus of a
telescope then you would you know put it
here on this side of the machine then
you go out a couple days later and do
the same thing and put your put your
photographic plate on this side of the
machine and then light would come on and
illuminate illuminate the plates and you
could flip between them with this wheel
and look through the viewfinder and
blink back and forth between the images
to look for differences between them and
so people would go out and do this and
you know here's a really famous example
of this this is Clyde Tombaugh he's an
American astronomer who you know this is
him using one of these in 1935 and
doing this you know led to a very
important astronomical discovery one of
the most important of the 20th century
basically by flipping back and forth
between these two images one taken on
January 23rd and then one taken six days
later of course it's all it's blindingly
obvious that this object is not here in
the second image right it's actually
moved over here and so this was this was
how how Buddha was discovered so you
know this this this problem of finding
changes in the night sky is is not only
a long-standing problem in astronomy but
it's also very important and it's led to
it's led to a major scientific you know
advances right so this is this is now
our image of Pluto whereas before it was
just this little dot flipping between
two photographic plates now we've
actually sent a spacecraft and mapped
out the surface of this of this minor
planet it's no longer a planet and in
great detail right and we've got these
beautiful images and and so so this so
this problem is extremely important in
astronomy and this is just to give you
an idea of of you know the kinds of
returns we can get by doing this okay so
I'm sure Peter mentioned this a little
bit but this is just a very quickly
supernova discovery 101 it turns out
that looking for supernovae and looking
for objects that move on the sky like
Pluto is actually very similar problem
we're doing something very similar to
what Tom Bell was doing basically you
take an image of the sky at some time
and now we have these fancy CCD
detectors which have digital readouts so
we can subtract away an image of the
same part of this guy from the earlier
time and then just have this digital
kind of matrix of this residual image of
subtraction which every point of light
on this image shows something that's
present in the new image that wasn't
there just in the image prior and so you
can have algorithms go through and and
you know check each one of these
detection of variability on this
residual image okay and it turns out
that this there's a blob of light here
in this in this new image that wasn't
here in the old one and actually that's
a supernova so this is kind of
schematically how we we search for these
changes in brightness on the night sky
today but there's a huge huge problem
with this a huge bottleneck which is
that more than 99% of the little dots
that you see on this image are total
garbage
they're absolutely bogus detections of
variability they're not Astrophysical
sources and in order to really discover
truly variable objects like the
supernova we need to go through all of
these detections of variability and find
the one little one thing that's actually
scientifically interesting so so I'm
sure you can imagine we're living in
this time of you know of machine
learning and this is 75 years ago and so
if you fast-forward you know 75 years
later from when this was going on to
maybe say 2005 I'm sure you would expect
there to be much more advanced way of
doing this right but actually the
technique really in 75 years - about
2005 hadn't really changed all that much
so the technique was - and here's this
is me doing a dramatic reenactment of
this to get a graduate student or more
likely an army of graduate students to
go through and instead of photographic
plates we now have these web pages and
you sit there and you click through each
individual object that you extract from
each of these subtractions and it takes
hours and hours and it's extremely
extremely tedious and many unfortunate
graduate students have lost hours of
their lives
to this process over the years but
but the the the the part that really
makes this different from from looking
for four minor planets like Pluto is
that four supernovae these things fade
away and we want to catch these things
early we want to learn as much about
them as possible and so we have we have
to send targets supernova targets to
telescopes like this for follow-up
observations and as Peter said this
telescope time is very valuable okay one
night on Keck is worth about $50,000 one
orbit of the Hubble Space Telescope
around the Earth is worth about $100,000
and so you know to make sure that we
really get the the best return on our
investment with this time we need to
make sure that the targets that we're
sending to these telescopes are actually
good and that we've gone through these
whole list of spurious detections and
made sure that we've really found all of
the objects that are actually
scientifically real and Astrophysical
and and sent the best ones off to go be
looked at in more detail and so the
Palomar transient Factory which which
Peter described was really the survey
that kind of ended this insanity for
good okay so so this was this was when
things really changed and you know and
basically as Peter said this is it's a
it's a survey based at Mount Palomar
using this distinguished Palomar 48-inch
telescope this telescope with a rich
history of making all kinds of different
scientific discoveries to robotically
scan the sky and take images of
different parts of the sky every single
night with it with a high cadence and
then when interesting objects were
detected they would use these other
telescopes a 60-inch here and the
200-inch to get spectroscopy of them to
follow them up in more detail this is
the camera 92 megapixels it can resolve
it can it can resolve something that's
about the width of a dime at a mile away
it takes about 300 of these exposures
every single night this is a picture of
a telescope here fully robotic
and in total it produces about 3,000 of
these of these CCD images every single
night so 3,000 of these chips which you
then go on to produce subtractions with
and then have to have graduate students
or maybe not anymore scan through all
the things that you find on them in
order to see if they're real or not
so this was a survey really when the
data rate was this was a first survey
where the data rank was so absolutely
mind-boggling lehigh that that this
manual scanning technique really just
ceased to be viable so it produced about
1.5 million detection of variability
every single night the vast majority of
these weren't real they could be
artifacts of the difference imaging
process or artifacts on the image
misalignment of the images its
saturation of the CCD from bright stars
about 50,000 of them were known
asteroids so not scientifically
interesting we already know about them
same thing with about a one or two
thousand of them being known variable
stars and out of this 1.5 million
objects about a hundred of them were
supernovae and just three to four out of
1.5 million every night were actually
new young supernovae that were really
scientifically valuable in an
interesting so this is a real needle in
a haystack problem and the first the
first kind of automated attempt to deal
with this was to use machine learning
and this this was a classifier that was
called the real bogus classifier one
okay this was this was pioneered by Josh
and basically the idea was to train an
automated algorithm in real time to do
the work that graduate students have
been doing for a long time and and take
the streaming data from the telescope
and pass it through pass it through an
algorithm and have it predict whether or
not each object was actually a real
Astrophysical detection of variability
or a spurious detection of an artifact
or something that was masquerading as as
real and so this was start work was
started on this
classifier at the very beginning of the
survey with so early on in the survey
that they actually didn't have real
ground truth labels to build a training
set yet so in order to create a training
set basically what was done was about a
thousand objects were assembled and
presented to a group of about ten or
eleven human scanners and then the
scanners were asked to - you know a pine
on whether or not they were they were
real sources of variability or whether
they were bogus and then by quantifying
the the the bias of each scanner so some
scanners were more optimistic they
tended to call things more likely to be
real whereas others were more likely to
call things bogus so by quantifying the
the bias of the skin are relative to the
group these labels were created for
these objects and a training set with
this distribution of kind of scores from
zero to one was was put together and so
then a random forest was was trained on
this it was a very very small sample
just about thousand objects to to
generate these so-called real bogus
scores so something with the real bogus
score of one is very likely to be real
something with a real bogus score of
zero very likely to be bogus and so so
this was tried out and it was actually
used in the broader context of this
classification robot also developed by
Josh which would query the date this
database of transients every 20 minutes
and compare new transients with archival
information to not only to - based -
basically look at the entire like curve
look at all of the detections of a given
object that had been that had been made
and tried to classify it at the next
level instead of just being real import
but
to actually say something about what its
nature was is this a supernova is this a
tidal disruption event is this a you
know a variable star etc and you can
read all about this and what's now
classic paper I think it's just got 100
citations automating discovery and
classification of transients and
variable stars in a synoptic survey era
in parallel at the same time there was a
different approach that was being taken
in the survey to solve this problem and
this was just by crowdsourcing this
problem of scanning out to the world so
instead of using ten or twenty graduate
students you could the idea was to
publish the this data set on the
internet and have people all around the
world go through and click through and
and do this scanning for the
collaboration so it was a part of this
galaxies new project which was a citizen
science project to have people look at
images of galaxies and try to classify
them based on their morphology in the
way that they looked and so in 2010
Peter spent a week with the folks at
Oxford setting up the database giving
them training sets of good and bad
candidates and the Oxford folks did the
rest about 1200 people
screened all of the candidates that were
found between August 1st and August 12th
in just three hours so it was very there
was a lot of interest in this and
certainly they were the volunteers were
able to get through the data very
quickly the top 50 things that they
found were all super number of variable
stars and actually were able to find
three before the survey scientists
themselves did and in total they scanned
about 25,000 objects which translated to
a rate of roughly 3 per minute and the
the kind of steady state usage
statistics were that they did about 250
of these nightly and there were 15,000
people around the world who were
participating this at peak and so
basically the way that it worked was you
would be presented with an image of a
subtract
subtraction object and they would be
asked a series of questions and a
decision tree like this is there a
candidate centered in the crosshairs of
the right-hand image has the candidate
itself subtracted correctly etc etc and
by responding to each of these questions
a score would be built up and
and and that score would would
essentially determine the realness of
the object and so here you can see they
did a pretty good job separating
supernovae from the chaff so this is the
distribution of scores of all candidates
the vast majority of which are garbage
and you can see it's really peaked here
at a value of minus 1 and then the
supernovae have a significantly
different distribution from this and so
you can you can see that that people
were able to pick these out relatively
well and there's a paper on this that
you can read galaxies through supernovae
that detailed this project so this is
really a great example of what became
the new normal with this automated
real-time decision-making alert system
with this real-time decision-making
system in place for the survey basically
mere hours after the first detection of
this supernova it had been passed
through the Oracle automated robot that
classified the light curves and filtered
away from the chaff of all the other
detection that were being generated by
the survey and just a couple of hours
later people had already reacted to the
discovery of this object and manual
alert was issued at the Weitzman
Institute a collaborating institution of
the survey and within just within just
less than one day after the first data
was taken on the telescope telescopes
all around the world had been triggered
to get more data of this object and you
can see what an amazing difference it
made getting this object so early this
is a spectrum that was obtained one day
that was obtained early on in the
evolution of this object and here's a
spectrum that was obtained just one day
later so getting this earlier getting
the spectrum just one day earlier really
you can see that you're a there there
was a huge amount of change between the
two and getting this early data really
allows you to see that this thing is
evolving quite quickly you get all of
these interesting lines and feature
and they were able to just get this
beautiful multiband like curved data set
and so this was really this was really I
think a transition point from when
looking for supernovae was largely
manual to really exploiting the full
benefits of real time decision making
okay and of course another major
discovery that was made with this
automated system was super number 2011
fue Peter talked about this
it's a closest type 1a supernova in the
last 25 years
fifth brightest supernova of any type in
the last century and it was caught just
11 hours after explosion it this this is
a totally unprecedented discovery of a
supernova so early and a bite by using
this machine learning classifier to
catch this thing and filter out all the
other spurious detections so that the
scientist could dive straight to the
detection of 11 Fe they were able to get
an unprecedented data set with
telescopes from all over the world even
amateur astronomers fought this thing up
and this is now the best observed type
1a supernova in history and it's
provided really a template for
understanding the physics of type 1a
supernovae and comparing all of the
other detections of this event that we
get to what has now become what people
think of as a most normal type 1a
supernova that's ever been found
okay so PTF ran for a 4 or 5 years and
afterwards there was a new incarnation
of PTF called IP TF the intermediate
Palomar transient Factory and the main
difference between IP TF and PTF was a
modernization of the software pipeline
that was used for the survey and so one
of the main updates that was made was to
update the machine learning pipeline
that was used for automating artifactory
action and so this is this is just an
example of some of the artifacts on I
PTF images versus the real sources on IP
GF images you can get a sense of the
morphological differences that you see
between the artifacts and the supernovae
and the main differences here were that
this real bogus classifier too was used
in IP TF both of these real bogus one in
real bogus two were trained on PTF data
but whereas the training set for real
bogus one was done with this group of
experts this groupthink expert labeling
by the time of real bogus two there was
already enough data that the survey had
taken to build a training set of ground
truth objects and the training set was
significantly larger now they were able
to get about 78,000 sources to train
with and the complexity of the model
also increased so whereas they were
using 27 time domain features or a shape
and brightness features to classify
objects with real bogus one now they
were using 42 for real bogus to an
interesting thing that they did was
improving their model by recursively
eliminating features with this backward
feature selection algorithm so they
started with the full model at the
bottom and recursively removed features
that improved the figure of Merit that
the training figure of Merit for the
random forest and so you can see here
that by by removing features in this
fashion you can drive this figure of
Merit down a better classifier has a
figure of Merit that's that's as low as
possible and then they stopped when this
ROC curve was went below a false
positive rate of 1% with only a few
features left in the model so this one
of the really great things about this
process was that they were able to
eliminate about half of the dimensions
of their parameter space with just six
hundred and ten iterations whereas if
they tried
every possible subset of parameter space
like the power set of the parameter
space brute force that would have taken
10 to the 11 steps and they were able to
improve the performance of their
classifier significantly by removing
features and so so this this was a big
win and actually it was with this rb2
classifier that not only did the
performance of the machine learning beat
humans in terms of time it actually
started to beat humans in terms of
accuracy so this is a receiver operating
characteristic showing the miss
detection rate as a function of false
positive rate for the machine learning
class of our rb2 and the human decisions
from the citizen scientists and what you
can see is that is that for a data set
of known supernovae the machine learning
at this point actually did significantly
better than the humans that were out
there so now we now there's a real time
decision-making framework for AI PTF
that outperforms crowdsource supernova
discovery and so while this was it was a
great way to start the project and a
good form of public outreach it actually
became outmoded and no longer necessary
for the survey so there here are some
other things about the classifier
performed very well but one thing that I
that I want to mention is that you know
this technique really caught on and so
one of my first projects as a graduate
student was to take this this classifier
that was developed specifically for AI
pgf and actually try applying it to a
different survey with a completely
different telescope a completely
different instrument different science
goals and and this is this was something
that I did my first year of graduate
school it this was a dark energy survey
supernova survey produced about 170
gigabytes of data every single night a
million objects per season so less than
the data rate that we were seeing from
PTF but also the survey was covering a
much smaller area
sky again the vast majority of these
things were artifacts and we had life
target follow-up almost every week so
this was another case where this were
machine learning was was really
necessary and so again we used a random
forest trained on on features derived
from from the difference images and from
their context and ones that passed a
certain threshold could go on to be
looked at by humans where it's ones that
that failed the threshold were piped off
to to be ignored and so just some key
results from from this project auto scan
the name of this code that I developed
reduced the overall scanning load by
over an order of magnitude with just a
one percent loss in efficiency for
finding these supernovae it took the
work that was being done by about 30
people and reduced it down to just two
people and now this this pipeline is
being used to guide the development of
similar pipelines for future surveys and
I just want to point out that all of the
data and code that I used to write this
algorithm is available online it's
become kind of a standard problem now I
think in an astro machine learning and I
think there there are also some computer
science groups that are looking at this
data set as well so I encourage everyone
to check this out download the data if
you think you can do this better than
we're doing it in DES highly encouraged
that achieved record-setting performance
on this task so when just 1% of the
spurious objects are being labeled real
we're losing just 6% of the real
detection so that's that's a really that
at the time that this came out that was
that was a record-setting performance on
this task and now I just I just want to
say that you know this has really become
a cottage industry this is this is now
the standard way of doing supernova
searches there were a whole bunch of
papers that came out after this
just setting up try trying to improve on
this setting up trying convolutional
neural networks for this trying to
combine human and machine
classifications applying this stuff to
different surveys and so now the era
where people are looking at the
subtractions to scan for candidates is
really over so we've entered a time
where it is a standard thing for
supernova searches to to completely
remove human beings from from this loop
where they played an integral role for
many many years okay now I just want to
talk about the implications of this
the new frontier we're living in a
really exciting time right now and in
terms of supernova searches because
we're about to get a slew of new surveys
that are going to be doing supernova
searches on a completely different level
than anything that's ever been done
before ztf and LSST are the ones that
I'm going to focus on so ztf is the
successor of PTF uses the same network
of telescopes here at Palomar
Observatory the survey telescope will be
the p48 here is the PTF camera I showed
this earlier in my talk cover 7.26
square degrees there's a new camera
that's been developed and it's going to
be put at the prime focus of the P 48
it's significantly bigger and so this
ztf survey will survey the sky an order
of magnitude faster than the PTF survey
it's going to be able to cover
3,750 square degrees per hour which if
you guys are an astronomers but take my
word for it this is unbelievably fast
it's really just crazy there's never
been anything like this before it's
gonna get 250 observations of each
region of the sky per year yeah can you
translate three pi survey yeah so the
whole sky is four pi so it's like 75% of
this guy each each field is going to
have 250 observations
per year so we're gonna get really well
sampled variability catalogs of huge
areas of this guy out to a pretty pretty
large depths and the data rate is just
going to be way way higher for this than
what we experienced with PDF and then
LSST is really going to change the game
this is this is a totally unprecedented
instrument it's being built right now
out in the mountains in Chile on in the
Andes it's going to take about a
thousand images each night each one is
going to be three point two gigabytes
and the size of 40 full moons and it's
going to produce 15 terabytes of data
every night for 10 years it's going to
cover about 40% of the sky and it's
going to discover tens of billions of
objects and it's going to observe each
one about a thousand times so this is
actually a way to think about LSST is
it's going to be the first movie of a
night sky over 10 years we're going to
be able to actually see this huge area
of the sky and in tens of billions of
objects evolve over time with these
amazingly deep repeated exposures and
that this is this is really going to
take it's going to completely transform
astronomy I think it's going to be able
to survey 40% of the sky every three
days so roughly a third of that per
night by the numbers ztf is going to
detect one trillion detections of
variability so the objects that remember
the points of light that I showed in the
difference image of different images at
the beginning over the duration of the
survey one trillion of those will be
produced and then for LSST we're going
to have 7 trillion a huge amount of data
ztf will detect 1 billion distinct
objects and LSST will detect almost 40
times that and each night we're going to
have so many detections of variability
that each that we're going to have to
move to a totally different model of
distributing the fact that we've made
these detection x' so now we are going
to this alert based system that's
real-time kind of
avro alert based system where every time
we find something that we think is
varied we're going to issue an alert out
that anyone in the world can go pull
down and try to do science with there's
just going to be so much pixel data that
actually the pixels are no longer going
to be available to the scientists so a
million of these are going to come from
ztf every night and ten million from
LSST and we're gonna try to get these
out and as near real-time as possible so
for LSST we're aiming to to get these
alerts out just 60 seconds after we make
the original discovery and for ztf the
goal is to have it within 20 minutes so
this is both a blessing and a curse as a
blessing you know these datasets are
totally unprecedented we're going to be
able to make you know the question is
like what amazing discoveries are
waiting to be made and in these
unprecedented datasets we're going to be
getting so much data every single night
that you know that the possibilities are
really exciting but of course now we
have a lot more pressure on the
real-time automated decision-making
infrastructure to separate the huge
amount of chaff from the real scientific
discoveries that were interested in just
one example of the possibility of these
surveys is something that I personally
am really excited about this is this
this notion of strongly Len supernovae
so Peter told you about supernovae and
and and why they're important for
astronomy now we're getting to the now
we're getting to the point where we can
actually try to routinely discover
things that are really really rare so
now the supernovae are the chaff and now
we're looking for the very rarest rarest
of a supernova and we have to filter
through all of the things that are you
know just two or three years ago we
would have considered ourselves lucky to
find so basically the picture of what's
going on here you've got a supernova
that goes off far behind this is a movie
yeah you've got a supernova goes off far
behind and almost perfectly aligned with
a foreground galaxy and the
gravitational field of the galaxy
actually distorts space-time and sets up
multiple null geodesics that light can
travel along from the supernova to earth
and so the upshot is that you see the
same supernova in multiple different
places on the sky and they're magnified
by different amounts and even more
amazing thing is that because each image
of the supernova is travelling a
different geometric path to reach us and
because the geometric paths have
different lengths there are actually
time delays between the multiple images
of the supernova so light emitted by the
supernova at the same time will reach us
at different times traveling through the
different images this is just a
simulation showing that you can see one
supernova and four different places
because it's being lenss by this
foreground galaxy here and this is
actually the galaxy that's hosting the
supernova but it's been so distorted by
the gravitational field of the
foreground galaxy that actually just
looks like a ring and so so this is the
the cool thing about this is that now if
we find these we can actually have
multiple chances to observe the same
supernova so the the picture here is you
know we've got our stronger than
supernova and what if we actually
discovered the system when it looked
like this we know there's going to be
another image coming and it's going to
be exactly the same as as these three
just delayed in time a little bit if we
could discover this in real time and
follow it up rapidly then we could
actually anticipate the arrival of this
image and get the very very earliest
time data of a supernova that we could
so you're if you remember 2011 F EE it
was considered revolutionary to discover
a supernova 11 hours after it blew up
now if we can actually know where a
supernova is before it happens then we
can imagine catching the very first
seconds of a supernova because we know
exactly when to look for it so this is
just one you know kind of science
project you could imagine doing with
this power so a core collapse supernovae
is the explosion of a really massive
star so the star can't support
self under its own gravity anymore and
it collapses it forms this neutron star
which bounces and sends the shock wave
careening outwards through the star yeah
it doesn't always give you for sometimes
it gives you too sometimes
detective pattern in the sense of
because because we know how gravity
works so this is all governed by general
relativity
so actually what what people do is they
try to model the mass distribution of
the lens and they try to model in the
absence of lensing the position of the
source and that actually gives you a
deterministic prediction of how many
images should there be and what should
their time delays be and so that model
is you know we have a high degree of
confidence in general relativity so it
it should it should work pretty well
that's actually the the part where
there's a little bit more uncertainty is
actually modeling the mass distribution
of the galaxies that's that's doing a
lensing because a lot of the masses is
in Dark Matter so we can map out the the
distribution of luminous matter but what
the lensing is sensitive to is the total
is the total mass and so yeah there's
some uncertainty on on what actually
that mass distribution is and that will
be the main driver of the uncertainty on
when we see that next image of the
supernova
so anyway now we now we can actually
talk about trying to catch the very
first seconds of a mission from a
supernova and that this is this is
really kind of cutting-edge stuff when
it when this shock driving the explosion
of the star breaks out it dredges up all
this hot gas behind it which is really
UV bright and so you get this almost
delta function like blue light curve
that's that's just it lasts about half
an hour it's just the shock breaking out
of this star and and that the width of
it actually tells you about how big the
star is that's exploding so now if we
imagine doing this multiple times we
could imagine trying to systematically
understand the properties that and their
lives as supernovae by using strong
lensing as a tool to to catch the very
earliest data on these explosions so
that would be really cool problem is
that these things are super super rare
only to struggle and supernovae have
ever been found here they are this is
the whole field right now this beauty is
called supernovae Rev stall it was
discovered with the Hubble Space
Telescope you can see this is a real
astronomical image there's this massive
galaxy right here and for images of the
same supernova around it and then the
host galaxy is kind of this blue blob
that's being distorted and then just
last year I PTF actually found a second
stronger than supernova this you know
this this beautiful object is IPG f16 gu
you can see the four images of the
supernova here and then it's being
lensed by this kind of blobby galaxy
here with the host galaxy around like a
ring and this was the first strongly
lense type one aid that was ever found
so we're going to be getting trillions
of detections of variability with these
surveys we're bound to find a good
number of these of these strongly lens
transients but actually now we're at the
level where in order to find these super
super rare objects these really really
new cutting-edge things we have to take
this real time decision-making to a
completely new level and that's that's
this idea of transy
Brokers so even with machine learning
these upcoming sky surveys are going to
produce so many alerts that now we can't
even have humans inspect the
Astrophysical ones anymore
we have to actually use automated
brokers to determine which objects are
scientifically interesting or unusual in
addition to Astrophysical and so so now
we're starting to see papers come out
about you know real-time decision-making
frameworks to automate this process
another way to look for so I I'm I
personally am interested in this
strongly and supernova problem so I've
been thinking a bit about this lately a
different way to do this would be well
what if we could actually find all of
the galaxy galaxies strong lenses and
that way any time we saw a transient and
one of them we could just immediately
follow it up this is an image
classification problem so there's a
strong lens in this image can anyone
find it saying that's yet yeah okay if
you said it was this you're right yeah
so there's no supernova in this but but
you can see there's this massive
elliptical galaxy here and then there's
this background galaxy that's being
lense into a ring and you can see it you
know if we could somehow train an
algorithm to to go through and from all
of these objects just tell us that this
one is actually a strong gravitational
lens then we would be in a really good
position to find these rare supernovae
and so there's been some really exciting
work recently about using convolutional
neural networks for this problem one
example that I've heard about just
recently is this code called CMU deep
lens and basically what they did is
train a deep residual network basically
just a kind of a slight variant on a
typical confident with 46 layers on
simulated lenses and non lenses that
LSST would look at and basically this
this this code achieves really
remarkable performance it can classify a
nine hours a sample of a hundred million
lens canada
and so already in just a few hours we're
starting to approach that tens of
billions of objects number that LSST is
expected to find over the entire 10-year
duration of its survey and that's on
just one card on one single GPU and so
deep learning will let us handle the
volume and data rate of these feature
surveys and definitely feed into the
real-time decision-making capability and
you know just as another example of
computers being the right way to do
astronomy now this automated lens finder
is is faster and more reliable than
human volunteers that were asked to to
make the same decisions on the same data
set last thing I want to talk about
scientifically is you'll remember I
started this talk by discussing the
discovery of Pluto and I'm sure as you
all know Pluto is not a planet anymore
but the same guy Mike Brown who killed
Pluto is actually now predicting that
there's another planet out there going
around the Sun but it's much bigger it's
about ten times the mass of the earth
and it's much much farther away it's
about a thousand times the distance from
the earth to the Sun whereas Pluto is
only 40 okay so so basically the way
that that this planet was inferred the
presence of this planet was inferred was
using mostly public data about comet
orbits so looking at comets Mike Brown
and and his colleague konstantin batygin
noticed that they're all clustered
gravitationally in a very unusual way
and if you add a very massive planet out
at a at a great distance you can
actually explain this effect okay and so
this is a slide from Josh but basically
Josh's prediction is that the data that
actually have photons from this planet X
have already been taken and and it's
it's very likely that that you know we
can detect this planet using data that
we already have and and it'll be you
know a group of astronomers and
statisticians with a lot of compute
resources that will actually be able to
go back and rest
spectively discover this planet and data
that's already in the can and so that's
exactly what we're working on in our
group right now with Michael Medford a
fellow graduate student in the Astronomy
Department and Peter we've developed a
technique to try to do this for the
first time and this was actually on the
cover of the I Triple E spectrum
magazine a couple of months ago and
basically the idea is that just like in
gravitational lensing we understand how
gravity works and gravity is what
governed through orbits of planets
around the Sun can we understand how
that works we understand Keplerian
orbits so the idea is to try out every
possible orbit that this planet could
have and shift all of the millions of
images from PTF along all of these
millions and millions of possible orbits
and try to add them together to increase
the signal to noise of the planet and
once we find the right one we think
we'll be able to see the planet much
much better so here's kind of a video
explanation of this idea so if the
planet were bright then if we took a
bunch of images separated in time we
would see it kind of puffing it across
the images here as the earth goes around
and and and you know we see this
parallax motion but actually it's much
more likely that this planet is faint
and so in a single image it's much more
likely that it'll look like this it'll
be much dimmer than the sky noise so
we'll just in a sink in a single image
we won't be able to see this thing at
all but if we try out the correct orbit
and shift these images along that orbit
then what will happen is the signal from
the planet will add coherently and we'll
be able to see it come out of the noise
because we've actually found the orbit
that it's lying along and the images are
being shifted correctly and so we're
working on on doing this search with a
supercomputer at nurse right now but of
course this technique is going to be
swamped with false positives so it comes
back to this real-time decision-making
idea we're going to need to use the
lessons that we
with the real bogus classifier and an
auto scan to winnow the spurious
detections that this technique is going
to produce from the real ones otherwise
this would be completely unattractive oh
we back to the situation where we've got
a bunch of human beings looking at all
of all of the possible planets that we
find so yeah you know it could be that
there's this giant planet way out going
around the Sun once every 10,000 or
15,000 years and you know with these
real-time decision-making techniques we
actually have the opportunity to define
this thing if it exists so I just want
to conclude by saying finding changes in
the night sky is now like a billion
dollar plus industry there are lots of
new experiments that are being built
that cost you know when you sum them all
together I think it's like a few billion
and you know real-time decision-making
pipelines and specifically machine
learning have have really been the
algorithmic advance that have enabled
this problem to reach this scale so it's
an exciting time to be working on this
kind of thing and it'll be really cool
to see what kind of discoveries we could
make aided by these pipelines in the
near future Thanks
yeah we've told this 11 about very
fascinating astronomical discoveries and
I wonder is a theoretical computer
scientist could my role be in helping
out so I was hoping to glean some more
about the algorithmic details but I
can't really see much I can see baby
pictures I think you know I think there
there are lots of opportunities for
algorithmic innovation in how we
identify these objects in this stream of
detections that we're going to be
getting from future surveys like LSST
what is the best way to to mark an
object as interesting if we've never
seen it before
you know if we have heterogeneous
unevenly sampled time series data how do
we how do we actually process that in a
uniform way and given you know
incomplete training data sets how do we
how do we produce an algorithm that can
actually take this streaming online data
and and say something interesting about
things that it hasn't seen yet I think
that's one of the biggest challenges
that we're facing right now so if I had
to say one thing I would say that's kind
of where the action is right now and I
think there's a lot of opportunity to
get involved especially with this broker
with these transient brokers that I
mentioned just in one slide but I'm
happy to chat more about that if I hope
that answered your question
the seems like all of the machine
learning algorithms that you describe
use the residual image of two images
yeah point in going to higher order
differences may be looking at three or
more images the same sky and looking at
kind of looking the second derivative in
to speak terms of the transitions yeah I
think that about that in principle would
would be an interesting thing to look at
the problem is that you can see just on
the first order version
how many artifacts we get and I think if
we I think if we you know apply that
process multiple times we can imagine
compounding the number of astrometric
misalignments and other things that
Pradaxa Lehrer sponsible for the
situation that we're in in the first
place so I think image subtraction is a
difficult problem that is numerically
unstable and prone to producing
artifacts so I think we would like to
avoid it as much as we can but I think
if if we can improve the quality of that
algorithm then in principle things like
that would be possible and I have
actually never heard of a case where
people have have done that so it could
be it could be an interesting thing to
look at what we did with that the IBM
TrueNorth chips which you can sort of
program
and what we did was took three different
detection along with their error images
as well which helps with the problem
that any so one of being a six
dimensional problem that we're passing
through and it did fairly well on that
but the things that you have to worry
about are you know are the images taken
at the same time what do you allow
they're taking slightly different times
is there some knowledge that it could be
bright say in blue but not in the red
and how do you weigh that so all of
those things have to be factored in when
you train one of these things
I think another that's actually kind of
thinking back to your question that you
just asked
I think another interesting Avenue to
explore here could be how do we detect
changes in the night sky without
actually having to subtract images is
there a way to to to Train some kind of
algorithm that can actually be sensitive
to changes in brightness and that
doesn't actually involve this image
subtraction process like could you just
put in two images into some kind of a
deep neural network and have it go
through and identify physical
Astrophysical changes in brightness and
localize them without actually having to
do this process that's so prone to to
producing spurious objects that that
would be an interesting thing as well
yeah
maybe both questions in the past we've
always think involved in the notion of a
discovery is two kind of inference that
this is interesting so there's the is
this real or bogus is the thing that
Danny's focused on and then there's a
whole other question of the two Peters
talked earlier do we actually follow
this up and spend telescope resources if
you now conflated those two questions
where you said both at the time this got
read is this a real thing or not and am
i interested in going after that there
then you get into really interesting
questions of you know for instance do I
need to take more data before I get
confidence that this may be an
interesting thing to go after and I
suspect you might be other write down
some optimization metric that allows you
to answer that there's the question of
do is this a discovery of a supernova of
a sort that I want to spend telescope
resources on at what level of confidence
do I have to then spend the you know
resources that are very expensive after
that to do that follow-up and right now
we've been sort of breaking those
problems up sequentially but if the
ultimate metric is to take data on you
know something that's going to show up
on the front page of the New York Times
if you if you try to figure out ways to
catch the problem not sequential sense
but just sort of overall was the final
outcome I think there'd be some really
interesting things to do there which
would involve multiple images in
multiple times it would involve sort of
bringing in sparse information from lots
of disparate catalogs because some parts
of the sky of an extremely well study
for and at the time of observation you
actually have in principle access to all
of that other data there are other parts
of the sky that in a very early study at
other wavelengths and bringing in the
metadata from that bringing in the time
history of what you've observed on your
survey and not and asking the question
about is this worth me spending
telescope resources on rather than is
this real focus or not maybe the the
next thing that starts on a plate
maybe this is an aspect of it that
comment oh so it seems as though in
terms of telescope resources you give me
high-resolution spectroscopy one yeah I
mean there there are lots of
difficulties yeah I mean spectroscopy is
definitely one of the one of the
fundamental and most widely sought after
types of follow-up that we obtained but
different science cases call for
different types of follow-up it's always
limited yet to the intensity yeah yeah
we're always yeah we're we're absolutely
limited by follow-up resources unless
this tea is going to discover you know
millions of supernovae we only have but
the number of follow-up telescopes that
we have which is already saturated and
oversubscribed it's not really growing
down at the instrumental level say it
again taking taking intensity versus
spectral iris of higher resolution
chemical characterization is that an
inherent split of resources or could you
could one imagine so you're asking
resolution per pixel spectroscopy
collapsing that yeah well the problem I
mean you don't always want your off yeah
yeah yeah you don't always want to go to
high resolution though right because
each pixel will have an inherent noise
associated with it and so so you you can
actually in some cases you can actually
beat down noise by using a lower
resolutions spectral instrument if if
you don't need it it guess one of the
inherent aspect is if your integration
times for spectral purposes are
approaching the
at the time of evolution yeah processed
well then you're caught yeah I think you
always want to use the lowest resolution
spectroscopy you can get away with if
you go to higher and higher resolution
then you're gonna end up wasting a lot
of time getting a to go after something
that you could have done with a lot less
exposure time on something that's but
that's something more than just a couple
filters yeah
and puzzled by this idea of marching
through a list of possible orbits to
track them this isn't the number of
orbits uncountable if if we had an
infinitely high-resolution image then
yes but because because the image is
pixelated
it's discrete so the pixel scale
actually sets the number of orbits that
you can step through but it is quite
large it's what you have I mean no we
look at all different inclinations as
well no no there there look for this
purpose but conceivably you could do
there techniques that could be useful
actually the number of orbits you have
to try increases exponentially as you
move the planet closer and closer to
Earth because then because if you're if
you're very far away then essentially 90
plus percent of the motion that you
observe is due to the Earth's motion
around the Sun and so it's a parallax
effect but as you move the planet closer
and closer to the earth the
contributions from the planet's proper
motion end up becoming more and more
important so the size of the parameter
space that you have to search over ends
up increasing by like three or four
parameters and so it ends up being a
harder problem but in principle if you
had a big enough computer you could do
it so if it's mostly parallax then it is
confined to a plane it's confined to the
plane of error order the motion even if
the orbit has a high inclination the
motion that you're seeing from parallax
is is in our plane well well so not not
not quite there is still proper motion
component but it's small it's small
enough that it does matter over ten
years which is kind of a time-based line
that we're looking
and it's enough to kind of it's enough
to kind of cause deviations from
parallax sight that you have to scan
over but it's at the level where it's
tractable and you don't have to it's not
as it's not as computationally intensive
as if we were looking for something that
was like at the orbit of Mars for
example where there are lots of
different shapes that you can see on the
images but yeah I'm the fact that it's
the fact that it's far away actually
helps us for exactly that reason you
know you were to go get something that's
a really good question and I think I
would say that in most of the cases that
I've seen it's almost always driven by
some kind of serendipitous discovery
that leads you to formulate a theory
like for example with the planet 9
[Music]
hypothesis the whole reason that that
people thought that it could be there in
the first place is because people were
looking for for things like Pluto out
you know maybe 40 earth distances away
from the Sun and they happened to
discover that they showed this
clustering that was very strange and
that led them to to make this hypothesis
that there was potentially this ninth
planet very very far away from the Sun
because that could explain this weird
thing that they found but it was that
but they didn't actually set out to do
that they just happened to notice it it
was just an observation and then that
led to this whole further line of study
and I think you know with the supernovae
stuff that that Peter and I have talked
about a lot of times it kind of happens
on the same lines you you make some
unexpected discovery that actually gets
your brain thinking and a stir
direction that you didn't set out to do
but now that you've found this thing you
know it sort of clicks together and and
so you know with with supernova it was
this empirical discovery that that there
brightnesses happen to be correlated
with the way that their light curves
evolved that actually enabled this whole
cosmological analysis that that Peter
discussed in his talk and you know I
think it's a lot of these questions are
you know yeah it's it's it's it's a
difficult question like takes the
gravitationally lensed supernovae we
know theoretically we've known for 50
years that these events should exist and
we've sat down and we've calculated the
race and basically you have to find
about 50,000 ordinary supernovae before
you see one of these where the alignment
goes and the final and so we knew that
they existed but we never found one and
then in PDF we found one and then I sat
down and thought well gee is there a way
we could optimize things so that we'd be
sensitive to finding these integer and
then we came up with this method to do
it which is really good and now we know
we're gonna find about 20 of them in the
zookie transient facility and about a
thousand of them in LSST nobody had
planned on doing that before so it's
really like it's taupe yeah and then
it's like oh I can optimize things to
find these thing we'd about nuts it's
never really planned out like yeah like
gamma-ray bursts for example which Josh
was was kind of like the world expert in
gamma-ray bursts you know the first
gamma-ray bursts were found using a spy
satellite that was looking for Russian
nuclear tests and it was sensitive to
gamma rays that you know and and it and
actually it went out in space and note
they were getting all the signal that
they didn't expect to find and it turned
out that it was coming from you know
distant objects far out in the distant
universe and so it was like the
surprising discovery that led people to
ask more questions and I think it's
maybe the question is how do we how do
we find the things that we we weren't
you know setting out to look for that is
there a way to automate that yeah I
don't know that's what you got that's
what we need you guys
that's the one thing that I can
guarantee is that you set up a survey to
find something you will find it but you
make blind yourself to a whole bunch of
other interesting things and so it's
really trying to not go down that rabbit
hole I think is where the excitement of
science is so when you're looking at an
omelet like when you look at these
different mystery so you're looking for
kind of a nominal anomalous anomalies
yeah exactly yeah I mean and a lot of
times we've probably missed the vast
majority of interesting ones because we
don't know what to look for for you to
tell given given the residual we care of
just imaging artifacts what at all in
terms of something missing artifact
versus anything else not supernovae but
yeah yeah right and the next step is the
next step is to actually build an
algorithm that can say something more
interesting about the physical nature of
the object that's producing the
variations and and detecting anomalies
there yeah is there a categorization of
a pipeline for generating anomalies and
and then working to suppress those that
those would say are instrumental yes
yeah that all happens at the level of
this real bogus stuff but I think it's
it's at the level of where we're gonna
be getting a million alerts per night
that are not artifacts and that are not
instrumental but are actual real
Astrophysical things how do we find the
ones that how do we find the ones that
are really interesting that we've never
seen before even though we don't even
really know what we're looking for
yes sir the question about these kind of
like imaging artifacts like do you
believe that they kind of acts like kind
of like white white noise like kind of
this independent white noise or do you
think that they're drawn from some kind
of like distribution that might depend
on the telescope that you just don't the
but the you don't it's kind of that you
don't know oh it's absolutely the latter
okay yeah it's absolutely the latter and
I the same question is even if it if it
is does depend on the telescope do you
still would it be would you expect it to
be like kind of independent between
different pictures but also between
different pairs of subtractions or could
it be even dependent on time because it
because if it was independent and you
could presumably take like pairs of
images that were both on either side of
the subtraction if you take multiple
pairs and like add together the
subtractions yeah in short nothing is
independent okay you know I could point
to some region of the sky where there's
a really bright star and that star is
gonna be so bright that actually it it
it saturates the CCDs and causes the
photons to bleed out to other pixels and
that will happen the same way every time
we look at that part of this guy and so
for that region of this guy we're always
going to see the same artifacts in
certain locations and you know sometimes
we get satellites going overhead and so
you know they leave these trails that we
actually pick up on the camera and so
you know that that will happen sometimes
but it's kind of random and sometimes we
get we get cosmic rays we get
high-energy particles that are actually
just going through space and then
they'll they'll hit the CCD and you know
saturate it and so that'll be yeah I
mean it's there there are not many
simplifying assumptions that you can
make
yeah so you lose it a couple of ways in
which you know how things can go to go
wrong and you can see something how do
you know there isn't something else
systemically that's interesting that we
don't know about you're seeing pretty
often you mean with the real bogus job
for I think it's I think it's really
just a question of we've had people
looking at this for so long that we kind
of have a sense of it at this point I
know that's not really a satisfying
answer but I mean there could be some
there could be some horrible systemic
that we're not aware of with the
subtractions but I mean I'm trying to
think of what one of those could be and
I'm having trouble I don't know Peter do
you have any there's a really good way
to test how well we do and how well we
do which is oh right right yeah
supernova blow up we'll see them we'll
find them when they're bright will
categorize them but you can of course go
back to the images where they're
signal-to-noise was lower or for
whatever reason you miss them they
didn't pass your machine learning
thresholds and then you can go study why
that was the case and that would be an
example we missed something go back and
understand why and model our
efficiencies that way the other thing
that we're very good at doing now is we
throw thanks on the images and we throw
them at different brightness levels and
stuff and then we've run our algorithms
on that and we study just the type of
effects you're saying certain portion of
the sky are we better at finding things
and others are they correlated with
bright stars bright galaxies etc and and
we can model our efficiencies all the
way through so when we do the rates we
actually
that type of work yes seem like that's
going to give you real accurate answers
for supernova detection right but if
there is like something that you are
classifying as an image positing
artifact that's actually real how would
you know so so you're talking about the
other way around where we it's a true
negative
I guess this way they were saying it's
true object but we've negatively
classified it I guess the thing is that
at least for everything that's
Astrophysical we can model exactly how a
little gear on the CCD know there's
there's only there's objects can either
be point sources where they can be
elongated due to motion and we can we
can model this and say how what we can
find on there's just there not other
things that we can look at it's it's a
very different than taking an image on
the street and trying to classify what
objects come into it or not because the
possibilities are almost infinite here
are the possibilities aren't so in
general if you took like if you have one
of these like I normally is can you
generally like say you grab like ten of
them would you be able to say why
they're anomaly yeah we did spend a lot
of time in the very beginning going down
and saying oh this was due to a cosmic
ray this was due to a satellite or an
airplane or a bright stars and and we
went through and we did that and we
found that at at no value labeling
putting those labels in there and trying
to train on it we just found the guy
yeah I didn't mean terms of trade more
in terms of that words therefore give
you be able to if you know why it's
anomaly that would presumably give you
more confidence that you're not falsely
rejecting something that does exist that
you don't earn a bit like but you just
but it doesn't look like something you'd
seen before as in like yeah I guess
we're I guess we're just really blind to
the fact that objects either move or
they stay still and we know how they'll
behave on a CCD if they did something
crazier then yeah we would like you know
we're not gonna find UFOs that do like
us so we're not good at that we find
things sort of do straight lines we'll
find things that are stationary so but
other than that there's not much you can
do yeah one thing to keep in mind to set
the atmosphere blurs out the shape of
objects in a very kind of well-known way
and because the things we're looking at
are so far away they are all so tiny
that that basically they just look like
they have this it's called a point
spread function they all just look like
this dot basically every everything
that's not a galaxy just looks like a
dot and so
that makes it easier
just as a check so no systemic bias
because of northern hemisphere southern
hemisphere issues or a station with
ecliptic Galactic plane that's it for
supernovas that's all kind of just yeah
I mean it's hard to find supernovae in
the galaxy or like when you're looking
through the galaxy because there's so
many stars in the field that it's hard
to do that image subtraction because you
have like this really densely crowded
ccd and it's just the algorithm breaks
down interesting galactic cluster
structure that's kind of uniform yeah
yeah
[Music]
Thank You Danny yeah thank you
[Applause]